The Incredibles 2's opening weekend may have
been a whirlwind success for Disney, but the
studio was met with a bit of unexpected backlash
once social media users began to voice their
concerns about one particular element of the
film.
"Looks normal to me…
What the!"
After one Twitter thread brought attention
to some intense flashing light sequences in
the film, Disney decided to issue a statement
warning viewers that the sequel features moments
that could potentially trigger those with
light sensitivities, particularly light-sensitive
epilepsy.
It all started when Twitter user Veronica
Lewis spoke up on Friday night to warn potential
Incredibles 2 audience members about what
goes down in the flick.
She explained that the film includes flashing
strobe lights that are used for extended periods
throughout the movie.
She also suggested that those who suffer from
issues like migraines, seizure conditions,
vertigo, and other conditions, may experience
a negative reaction to the imagery.
Lewis was quick to point out that the flashing
and strobing light effects are, quote, "an
important point in the plot," since the film's
villain, Screenslaver, uses flashes of light
to disorient and control his victims.
After Lewis' thread circulated, and others
agreed with her that Disney should have done
more to warn viewers, the company stepped
up to the plate and issued a formal warning
to be hung in theaters which reads:
"Incredibles 2 contains a sequence of flashing
lights which may affect customers who are
susceptible to photosensitive epilepsy or
other photosensitivities."
While the potential health hazard that could
result from these scenes in Incredibles 2
has not been confirmed, the studio took the
concerns seriously enough to act anyway.
The Epilepsy Foundation also released its
own statement to warn fans of the potential
for the Disney-Pixar film to induce seizures.
Incredibles 2 isn't even the first animation
to come with a warning.
Who can forget the infamous Pokemon Panic
of 1997, in which an episode of the hit cartoon
show had to be pulled from the airwaves after
it actually did induce seizures in hundreds
of Japanese children who watched its flashing
light fight sequence unfold on-screen.
Even with this new bit of sudden pushback,
though, Incredibles 2 is still on track to
be a major success for the House of Mouse,
after having a record-breaking $180 million
opening weekend.
But now, kids and adult audiences alike should
consider themselves warned that the film's
flashes may be more intense than previously
expected.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!